ever watch a show that first aired 10
years ago and then ended a few years ago
and you still want to talk about it yeah
it's like that HBO's the wire so the
wire was a show that was on HBO that ran
for five seasons between 2002 and 2008
and takes place in the great city of
Baltimore and concentrates on the war on
drugs from the point of view of the cops
and the drug dealers you get both in
this show right away I was like that's
interesting as hell that's one of the
coolest things ever because you always
see the cops point avidya all right yeah
good guys bad guys so we're just going
to concentrate on the good guys cops
going to make the drug busts and life
all makes sense but now you have the
point of view of the drug dealers also
and most of the most interesting parts
in the show take place from the point of
view of the drug dealers and what I like
about the shows that shows that the
whole drug dealing game is bigger than
just one person you know when one guy
drops and other guys gonna pick up the
sceptre and he's just gonna be the
kingpin of everything also and he's
gonna run with it so how do you win a
fight like that in any case on the cop
side ultimately concentrates on one cop
named Jimmy McNulty yeah Kirk Cuddy from
steel dragon and rock star that's what I
always knew him as until now now he's
Jimmy McNulty and he gets a team
together and they put wiretaps on phones
that the drug dealers use in the first
season they're using pagers which really
blew my mind I was like oh yeah those
things that no one no one remembers
anymore
but I'm telling you this is some
in-your-face cops versus street dealers
kind of [ __ ] here I don't think I've
seen a show this real some of the
smartest writing I've ever seen it's one
of those shows you know I watched a lot
of TV I watch a lot of shows after
watching The Wire the same thing happens
after you watch Breaking Bad shows that
you watch that you used to think with
just the smartest shows ever and now
look less engaging they seem less smart
darn good shows that always raise the
bar like the wire and every season the
wire deals with a thing you know a thing
that's kind of like do the ends justify
the means moral dilemma and I'll be
damned if 9 out of 10 times I'm not like
yeah total I would support that is it
legal nope but it works shows they get
you to think outside the box man that's
the kind of stuff that grips me one
thing that I found interesting in the
show is just the intro the intro song is
always the same song but it's sung
differently in every season I actually
found that really cool like I a totally
different vibe when you're going into
the show that's cool the only season
that's really out of place in comparison
to every other season is season 2 after
season 1 you're now accustomed to how
things work and whatnot you know
street corners and drug dealers you know
the faces you know the game season two
takes place on a completely different
aspect of everything I suppose it's
relevant because it does tie into stuff
but it's just a totally different vibe
in season three four and five go back to
you know what you liked about season one
and actually it's one of those things
where certain characters leave the show
and you're like the show's not going to
be good anymore that was like one of the
coolest characters but the show is still
great so like I will props to you
writers and people who work these things
out that are smarter than me but I'm
telling you season four snoop and Chris
hoof slips is one gangster thug chicken
almost never understand what she's
saying is you know we wouldn't go to
real [ __ ] no welcoming [ __ ] but
it doesn't matter he's one of those
actions speak louder than words types
because in season four I'm telling you
she's one of the scariest individuals
ever put on TV he just sees snoop in a
dark alley you're like I'm dead I'm done
dead man it was unsettling as hell
snip season four you get the creepiest
person ever put on TV award best
character in the show though my favorite
two words oh ma coming Omar little is
one of my favorite characters ever made
period on screen ever big screen small
screen wide screen it doesn't matter
it's Omar Omar is a straight-up wild
card in this whole game when asked what
he does in a court of law he just
replied I rip and run Omar Rob's drug
dealers at first it's just business then
it becomes personal then Omar is just
unstoppable but Omar's a guy with a code
he has a Cody lives by he never turned
his gun on someone who's not in the game
that's where I liked about the first
three seasons of this show it showed
that there's a system to it if you're a
civilian you're not just gonna get
wasted later on not so much seasons 4 &
5 I felt like I did back when I was a
little white kid in elementary school I
like if I walk down the city street at
night someone gonna kill me but not Omar
Omar he comin yo guess is the point Omar
just walking down the street and you
just hear people like Omar coming o
comment one of the coolest characters
ever I'm telling you there are two kinds
of people in the world people who
profess that the wires one of the best
shows ever made and people who profess
that the wire is absolutely the best
show ever made this is the in-your-face
realistic cops versus drug dealers show
that you might have been waiting for
however I will say if you don't like cop
shows you might not like the wire wire
is the definitive cop show it's kind of
like all right what's the definitive
fantasy show on TV oh it's Game of
Thrones all right what's the definitive
cop show ever put on TV oh it's a wire I
kind of
you're like I never want to watch
another cop show on TV because it's not
the wire the only weird thing about the
show is that it's not in high-def it's
in four by three aspect ratio that's you
know the aspect ratio there's like this
it's not widescreen and it's in standard
def I mean as the first season goes on
you get completely used to it and you
kind of appreciate you know the
grittiness and simplicity of it all the
absurdly unconscionable thing is that
the wire was never really nominated for
anything it was nominated for a few
words that I've never heard of but in
terms of Golden Globes Emmys nothing it
was nominated for like two Emmys one for
Best Writing in this episode and one for
Best Writing in that episode but no one
was up for Best Actor the show wasn't up
for Best Drama freaks me out now when I
see nominations I'm like okay that's up
but the wire wasn't that's [ __ ]
usually when I'm done with shows I'm
like okay it's done it's over it's sad
that it's over but I move on the wire I
want to watch it right now again
straight through at this very moment so
that's something I'm telling you it's a
great drama watch it however in the show
there is a character that gets totally
what I call Boba Fett and that person is
alive and now the person's dead deserved
a better going off than that but it just
kind of happened
which the show lets you accept that as
realism you're like yeah the show's
established that it's really realistic
and that's how it would happen it could
just happen like that so it doesn't make
you as mad as you think it would but you
still don't like it
so have you seen the wire and if not or
even if so what's your favorite show on
TV comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more OMA he coming
you